politicians involved in gun law protests
say their sit-in is over but that the
fight will carry on the members of the
House of Representatives had been
sitting on the chamber floor protesting
at the lack of action on gun control
measures a broadcast and radio host
Stephen Crowder joins us via Skype now
from Texas thanks very much indeed for
joining us the speaker described it as a
publicity stunt but what publicity well
it depends I guess on your perspective
on the issue for someone like me or
someone who respects the Second
Amendment or due process it's silly the
these are Democrat politicians pushing
something that it requires an uninformed
voting base to support the measures that
they're putting forward there were
measures put forward by Republicans time
and time again they shoot them down they
don't want gun control they simply want
control however clearly a lot of those
politicians indicated that this was a
reaction to what happened in Orlando and
a number of other shootings in various
public arenas and clearly there is a
growing debate within the United States
about what can be done about gun grill
particularly automatic weapons no no I I
hate to come on your show and correct
you but what you've just said is
entirely false and I'm not saying that
you're deliberately saying something
false but you said automatic weapons
respectfully I don't think you know the
difference being an automatic weapon or
a semi-automatic weapon not a single
automatic weapon was used in any of
these mass shootings mass shootings are
not on the rise gun crime is actually on
the decrease the weapons that were used
were semi-automatic weapons which
includes any handgun sold really since
the year I don't know nineteen fifty
except for a double-action revolvers and
the legislation that they proposed would
not do anything what they are talking
about these Democrats right now and I
know that people in the UK it may not
understand the history of the Second
Amendment or why it's a fundamental
right in the United States a big reason
was because we left it's it's an issue
here where these people want to use the
no-fly list for a litmus test let me
tell you there are hundreds of thousands
of people in the no-fly list in the
United States including Senator Ted
Kennedy Fox News contributor Steven
Hayes I've known half-a-dozen people
hundreds of thousands and the
administration themselves have said that
maybe one in a hundred have anything to
do with terrorism I do not believe that
a man
citizens who've been accused of no crime
who have not received any due process
should have their basic fundamental
human rights stripped away let me
clarify for people listening gun
violence is on the decrease nobody is
out there purchasing automatic weapons
no automatic weapons were used in this
shooting and isn't it interesting that
we pivoted from a guy who pledged
allegiance to Isis and went out and
killed 49 gay people because they were
gay in the name of Islam we're talking
about weapons that were never even used
what a pivot that is so are you trying
to argue assault rifles are less
dangerous than other weapons what's an
assault rifle
well you've described semi-automatic you
can have a semi-automatic assault rifle
as it was used in the Orlando shooting
that can spray bullets in a matter of
seconds well no I didn't say it you use
the term assault rifle you use the term
automatic correctly that's a police used
in Orlando when they describe what the
weapons that have been used assault
rifle is the term they use not my term
no I've seen that's the term the media
has used and I've seen the terms
describing the weapon they had recovered
at the scene can you sit in that
automatic is false and that maybe you
should retract that so your audience
understands that no automatic weapons
were used you trying to understand your
line of argument are you trying to say
there's a thing that's a safe gun for
instance of course yeah I have a gun on
my hip right now it's never shot anybody
why did you need a gun in the studio
well let me explain to you I actually
have a fatwa on my head because I've
drawn Mohammed so that's my reason and I
would never assume to actually copy
paste my reason or know the motive for
any person who might need their basic
fundamental human right to
self-preservation why do you need
security guards there in the studio I
haven't got security guards here in the
studio there's no security in that
studio no I've got a floor mat he's not
really I don't believe you just like I
don't believe that you don't know the
difference we know automatic and
semi-automatic let's go to the term
assault rifle to use your term it's the
term the police use if you want to be
specific about these things that's the
term the police use describing the
weapon recovered at the scene right so
no automatic which is patently false you
were wrong and we use the term instead
let me tell you what an assault rifle is
here's a gun that's legal an assault
rifle okay not the perfectly legal
change it to a pistol grip that's now an
assault rifle these are arbitrary
very reasons semi-automatics okay you
can get handguns that are far more
effective by the way are used much more
in mass shootings this is what's
important to note semi-automatic
handguns or rifles they can be in either
handgun or rifle they're more often used
in handguns with gun homicides are more
available than ever and gun crime in the
United States has taken a sharp downturn
meanwhile in the UK or Australia Western
Europe you can even look to Sweden where
guns are incredibly controlled violent
crime rate not gun related crime but
violent crime rate particularly sexual
assault have absolutely skyrocketed
because you have a defenseless populace
who don't have their right to
fundamental self-preservation but why
don't we talk about the guy who pledged
allegiance to Isis and killed gay people
the name of Islam I mean isn't that the
root cause here shouldn't it shouldn't
that be the main topic at hand
he killed in the name of Islam and said
he was doing so in the name of Isis
isn't that more important than a rifle
that he never used the ar-15 which was
misreported also misreported as
automatic why aren't we talking about
Islam well we have been discussing that
because on the very night Islamic state
claimed that he was as they say one of
their foot soldiers but as you well know
President Obama in his address to the
nation indicated this was the latest in
a series of mass killings involving
weapons but you appear to be indicating
that whether the weapon is automatic
semi-automatic or whether it's just a
handgun that's perfectly acceptable no
no I was simply saying you were wrong
and the fact that you're doubling down
makes me think makes me give you less of
the benefit of the doubt I assumed you
were ignorant makes it think that makes
think that you're lying now if you want
to fixate on that action we're just
getting some news from the automatic for
a moment was not using for a moment on
an issue that actually directly affects
this because the US Senate has just
voted to block a more restrictive plan
as they say to stop gun sales to people
on some terrorism watch this what I
think you said the no-fly list right so
you would go just talk you would agree
with that I would agree with what the
fact that it's it's correct to block any
restrictive plans to stop gun sales to
people that Allah terrorism watch you
know I'm trying to
and I appreciate let me come on your
program and rights are different in
different countries so I'm trying to
think of a fundamental human right that
would exist in the UK we know it's not
freedom of speech or the Second
Amendment it's a fundamental human right
in the United States to own a firearm
now again you have hundreds of thousands
of people in a no-fly list you can be
put on at any point for no reason with
no due process having never committed a
crime with no appeal process so do I
think that I want to hand over that
government the power to do that no of
course not I think someone needs due
process particularly American citizens
if you're going to strip them of their
rights people can throw around terror
watch lists again this shooting in
Orlando let's be clear he was not on a
terror watchlist
he didn't get a firearm through a gun
show loophole it wasn't automatic it
wasn't even an ar-15 everything that has
been repeated in the media including
many things here in this interview are
verifiably false thank you very much
indeed for joining us from there in the
studio I hope you've got your safety
cash in your weapon thanks very much
indeed